i think the most appropriate thing to
say to you is
welcome back nancy pants thank you
so why is now the right time to return
to the real housewives of orange county
yeah well i'm you know i think that
obviously timing has a lot to do with
most things and listening to the
universe you know if you had asked me
two years ago it probably would have
been a different answer
but when they called me
i laughed i was like yeah no that sounds
like a terrible idea and then of course
you know you explore every opportunity
and terry and i talked about it and what
we really started talking about was our
family and when my daughter max came out
as bisexual a couple years ago we got
flooded with you know really beautiful
supported messages and also messages
from people who didn't handle it
maybe the way they wanted to that were
estranged from their children or their
parents and also you know really tragic
stories as well
and so we started talking about hey
wouldn't it be cool we've got these four
kids different genders different
sexualities all you know figuring out
where they are in the world
and showing everyone our version of a
normal family and how we parent and how
i mother them and and how they relate to
each other and maybe we could start
those conversations in other houses
i love that and and speaking about max
and and obviously her feeling so
comfortable to be able to talk to you
about something that's such a big part
of her life what was that like for you
knowing that she felt comfortable to be
able to talk to you about that
i think that um we've always had an a
very very good line of a communication
which i'm incredibly proud of i grew up
in a very 1950s house where they just
didn't talk about anything everything
was kind of like brushed under the rug i
am the polar opposite diary of the mouth
i'll talk about anything
and i so my household is just the exact
opposite and i always wanted my kids to
know that they can come talk to me i
don't need to know everything
but
nor should i know everything they tell
me a lot though and um i'm really really
proud that that's our relationship so
she had told me um
i mean quite some time before she came
out but i didn't talk about it obviously
that's her story to tell so i didn't
really talk about it until she did it
publicly
ah hey listen true testament to you to
terry and just your whole family unit uh
so let's talk about the cast of orange
county i mean obviously big
personalities that's why we love
watching this show so much but that can
also
create great experiences and bad
experiences does your return to the show
have anything to do with the exit of
kelly dodd
um you know when they called me to come
back on the show
uh they sort of spelled out what the
show would they what they wanted the
show to look like what direction it was
going in and i just felt confident at
that time
that it was a trajectory that i was
comfortable with yeah nope that makes
sense when you were off the show did you
keep up with the episodes or did you
have to sort of binge the last few
seasons to really understand what all
the drama and everything that was going
on i did not watch the show and i did
not catch up so when i when i joined the
show the first time i went in blind i
was like i don't know these people i'm
not gonna go binge watch the show
and form opinions before i've met them
because in real life you don't do that
and i always felt like people are
allowed to have a clean slate so
you know maybe maybe you're known as
this person on the show but what if i
meet you and i see you as something else
you know let me form my own opinion so
when i came back this time the only
person i knew was shannon and so i felt
like
you know what i'm gonna do the same
thing i'm just going to come back in and
i'll meet people as i meet them yeah you
know speaking of shannon i think it's
fair to say you guys have had
some challenges in the past and some
rocky bits um
what how would you describe your
relationship this time around
well i think we both went in with
absolutely the best of intentions
because we hadn't really seen each other
in five years and i mean we'd bumped
into each other and texted a couple
times but but we didn't end on bad terms
so i i wasn't concerned and i and i felt
like we were both jumping in well and i
was actually excited because she had
texted me which found out i was coming
back and was reminding me about some
like fun trips we had taken together and
you know hit the nostalgia button so i
was i was in and then you know as you
see it kind of goes off the rails pretty
quickly
yes
um you know the cast has definitely
changed uh since you're off the show are
there any friendships that you've made
this time around that surprised you
um
uh you know i guess
i'm not i guess i was surprised that
gina and i i thought we would get along
because we're both from new york but i
was surprised how much like i so
loved her the moment i met her i didn't
expect that i didn't expect to just like
you know
want to just hang out with her and be
with her i mean we really bonded quickly
that's why the sushi party was so
disappointing
because i felt betrayed but then you
know afterwards when we had lunch and we
could talk about it and i heard where
she was coming from
then that kind of smoothed that over but
you know she and i just had so
much fun mm-hmm well you can see it and
you can definitely feel it which is so
awesome can we talk about your
ridiculously gorgeous home
yeah it's like it's so beautiful
fully completed so exciting um what is
your favorite part about this amazing
home
i mean there's so much i guess you know
the the typical answer would probably be
my closet because it's really fabulous
but
really i mean i love our kitchen family
room as many homes as we've lived in and
i think we've lived in terry and i've
lived in like 12 together or something
um
the we never had like that big kitchen
family room area and it when we when i
designed this home it was a must and
that's where we live i mean we just had
thanksgiving
here and um it was just the six of us
and it was like one of the best
thanksgivings we've ever had and it was
just in that room i just i love being
there that's like the heart of our
family
yeah i love hearing that so much and
just to wrap things up obviously uh it's
been some time since you've shared the
stream uh with vickie or tamra
what's your relationship with them right
now do you think they'll ever come back
to the show
my relationship was great i mean i ran
into vicki actually while we were
filming the show and it was great to see
her i'm very fond of her um tamara and i
are friends and i invited her to a party
on the show but unfortunately it didn't
work out okay gotcha that's awesome hey
listen so great getting to talk to you
i'm totally getting the wrap um but so
exciting and you know that fans love
that you're back which just must be such
a good feeling it's you know what it's
really kind and i really appreciate it
and i really loved meeting you morgan
thank you